Hey, Will. Good morning. I'm very excited for today's episode. Good morning, Jason. It is great to be here with you. Oh, no. Hey, Will 2.0, where's Mr. Arnett? It's me, your friend Will, for many years, and I just wanted to say from the bottom of my heart, I wish you all the best. I want you to speak to your master about trying to make your voice a little bit more realistic, because it would be helpful. Like, when he's late, like I guess today, we could actually use you on the podcast, but you sound a little mechanical. This is me, Will. I'm here to just... Jason!
嘿，威尔。早安。我为今天的节目感到非常兴奋。早安，杰森。很高兴能和你在一起。哦，不。嘿，威尔2.0，阿尔内特先生在哪？是我，你多年的朋友威尔，我只想发自内心地说，祝你一切都好。我想让你和你的主人谈谈，尽量让你的声音听起来更真实一些，因为那会很有帮助。比如，当他迟到时，我想就像今天这样，我们其实可以用你来录播客，但你听起来有点机械。这是我，威尔。我来这里只是……杰森！
What happened? I was stuck inside the virtual me, and I just... Did you sleep with your window open last night? Let's get down. Can we just start the old news smart list? Let's do it. Welcome to Smart List. Who are you playing with today? Don't worry about it. Hey, Sean.
怎么回事？我被困在虚拟的我里面，我只是……你昨晚睡觉开窗户了吗？我们开始吧。我们能直接开始那个老新闻聪明清单吗？开始吧。欢迎来到“聪明清单”。你今天在和谁玩？不用担心。嘿，肖恩。
Hey, guys. What's going on? I'm playing with some real respectable folks. Who? That's why your inbox is empty. Who are you playing with today? That's not me. Their names? You want their names? You don't know these guys. Well, we can bleep them out. Yeah, go ahead. First name James, first name Nick, and then guest of James.
嘿，伙计们。怎么啦？我和一些真正受人尊敬的人在玩。谁？这就是为什么你的收件箱是空的。你今天在和谁玩？那不是我。他们的名字？你想知道他们的名字？你们不认识这些人。好吧，我们可以消音处理。行，去吧。名叫詹姆斯，名叫尼克，然后是詹姆斯的嘉宾。
Who's James? Who? You don't need to worry about... Who shall I be directing my anger? I don't think you've played with him, but he did invite me. Otherwise, I would have invited you. Oh, okay. But let's play next week, please. Sean, you want to come play some golf with us next week? Oh, sure.
谁是詹姆斯？谁？你不需要担心……我该把怒火发向谁？我觉得你没跟他玩过，但他确实邀请了我。否则我会邀请你的。哦，好吧。不过我们下周玩吧，求你了。肖恩，你下周想和我们一起去打高尔夫吗？哦，当然。
You want to dork out with us out there? You got to wear one of these funny shirts. Yeah. Yeah. I just came from the range. No, did you really? Yeah, I dropped off Abel, and then I just went in and got a quick hour of work. Just working. Does Archie... What? Did you drop off Archie?
你想和我们一起在那儿装书呆子吗？你得穿一件这种滑稽的衬衫。嗯。嗯。我刚从练习场过来。不，真的吗？对，我送了亚贝尔去学校，然后我就去练了一个小时的球。就工作呗。阿奇他……什么？你送了阿奇吗？
Is he homeschooled now? Yes, I dropped him off first at the bus, and then Abel's last. That's right there. Does Archie ever get pissed off that Abel gets a door-to-door, and Archie gets dropped at the RTD station? He does not. What's RTD? Rapid Transit District. Isn't it? RTD? Boy, that fell apart quick.
他现在在家上学吗？是的，我先把他送到公交车站，然后亚贝尔是最后一个。就在那儿。阿奇有没有因为亚贝尔是门对门接送，而他被送到RTD（区域交通局）车站而生气？他没有。什么是RTD？区域交通局。不是吗？RTD？天哪，这话题崩得真快。
Yeah, well, guess what? Who here has ridden a public bus? I used to do it all the time. What are you talking about? Me? I don't need the face, Will. Just answer it. I used to write it a lot going to work. You know that story. Oh, man. You know, the medal ceremony is coming up, so we'll have to jot that down. Who's ridden the bus lately? By the way, for Jason, a bus is a Challenger 300. Anything below that he considers a bus.
对，好吧，你猜怎么着？这里谁坐过公交车？我以前经常坐。你在说什么？我？我不需要那副表情，威尔，直接回答。我以前上班经常坐。你知道那个故事。哦，天哪。你知道，奖牌颁奖仪式快到了，所以我们得记下来。最近谁坐过公交车？顺便说一句，对杰森来说，公交车就是一架挑战者300型飞机。任何低于这个级别的他都认为是公交车。
An air bus. Hey, have you guys ever ridden a subway here in Los Angeles, California? Never. I will not do it. Have you? I have. It freaks me out too much. I'm a big subway guy, but not here. Why? Because of the earthquakes? Yes.
空中公交车。嘿，你们有没有在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶坐过地铁？从来没有。我绝对不坐。你呢？我坐过。把我吓得够呛。我是个狂热的地铁迷，但这里的不行。为什么？因为地震吗？是的。
I don't know. And also, it doesn't really go to areas like, it goes from Hollywood to downtown. Wait, do they make a bigger drink than that? Or was that it? That's the max? It's the Trente. Wait, why did you take a subway, Jay? I'm glad you asked. It was the best way for me to get to the start of the Los Angeles Marathon. Sean. When was that?
我不知道。而且，它实际上不去那些地方，比如，它从好莱坞开到市中心。等等，他们有比那个更大的饮料吗？还是说那就是极限？那是特大杯（Trenta）。等等，你为什么要坐地铁，杰伊？很高兴你这么问。这是我到达洛杉矶马拉松起跑线最好的方式。肖恩。那是什麽时候？
Well, that sounds a lot of, you're a fat bastard now. This was, this was like 10 years ago. Oh yeah, okay. Yeah. Yeah, I don't need to take it because earthquakes happen underground and the subway is underground, so I don't need to go near that. Right. How much J-Fing did you have on the marathon? Yeah, I'm glad you asked that too. You know what they have there in the, if you run the
听起来你现在是个大胖子了。这是，这大概是10 years ago。哦，好吧。是啊。是啊，我不需要坐，因为地震发生在地下，而地铁也在地下，所以我不需要靠近那玩意儿。对的。你对马拉松有多少了解？对，我也很高兴你这么问。你知道他们在那个里面，如果你跑了
marathon, any marathon, I think, you will get some hot spots. Yeah. So they have... You can just swipe some goo. Go ahead. Just jump ahead in the story. Fuck. So they've got the... Well, take it longer.
马拉松，任何马拉松，我想，你都会长出一些痛点。是的。所以他们有……你只要抹点凡士林就行。说吧。直接跳到故事后面去。操。所以他们有……好吧，说详细点。
I mean, what the... Well, I'm setting it up. It's pretty good. You know what they have there. You know what they have there. Just get to the facts. I'm not Canadian. I'm not Canadian. You know what they have there. They don't sound like Eli.
我是说，什么鬼……好吧，我在铺垫。这挺不错的。你知道他们有什么。你知道他们有什么。直接说重点。我不是加拿大人。我不是加拿大人。你知道他们有什么。他们听起来不像伊莱。
So they've got tables. They got tables. They got tables of water, tables of Gatorade, and they've got a cardboard wall that a person holds up with a big patty of Vaseline on it. And this patty is like the size of a, I don't know, a large cake. And as you go by it, you're supposed to, yeah, as you said, we'll swipe with two fingers, the goo, and then start hitting your hotspots without ever breaking a stride. And you know where these hotspots are. And so if you come to the second Vaseline cake or third or fourth or fifth, you know those two fingers have already traveled, you know, at the last one.
所以他们有桌子。他们有桌子。他们有放水的桌子，放佳得乐的桌子，还有一个纸板墙，一个人举着，上面有一大坨凡士林。这坨凡士林大概有……我不知道，一个大蛋糕那么大。当你路过它的时候，你应该，是的，就像你说的，用两个手指抹一点凡士林，然后开始涂抹你的痛点，而且步履不停。你知道这些痛点在哪里。所以如果你遇到第二个凡士林蛋糕，或者第三个、第四个、第五个，你知道那两根手指在最后一个上面已经摸过很多次了。
So it's just, it becomes progressively more disgusting, but you have to balance that against the pain. I mean, obviously insert joke here, Sean Mecanos and swiping Vaseline. And I don't want to give you the... I mean, I was like... I'm just going to give you the bare bones of it. You know what I mean? I think there it's just buckets of olive oil, right?
所以它只是，变得越来越恶心，但你必须在这一点和痛苦之间权衡。我的意思是，这里显然可以插入一个笑话，肖恩·梅卡诺斯和抹凡士林。我不想给你……我的意思是，我当时……我只想给你最核心的东西。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得那里只有几桶橄榄油，对吧？
Well, have you ever ran a marathon? No. I've done a half marathon. That was rhetorical, Will. Sean, you? No. Again. I can't even...
好吧，你跑过马拉松吗？没有。我跑过半程马拉松。那是反问句，威尔。肖恩，你呢？没有。又来了。我甚至……
Not really. Yeah, you did do a half marathon, Willie? Yeah, I did. Yeah. My brother does that shit all the time. And he'll go... Sure he does. I've seen him in clothes.
说实话没有。对，你跑过半马，威利？对，我跑过。对。我弟弟老干这种破事。他会去……他当然会。我见过他穿衣服。
Yeah. He'll do a lot of like, you know, he'll be out for dinner and drinks. And he'll be like, I'll be like, I'm tired. He's like, me too. He's like, I did a half marathon this morning. This morning? What are you talking about? Yeah.
对。他经常会这样，你知道的，他会在外面吃晚饭喝酒。然后他会说，我会说，我累了。他会说，我也是。他说，我今天早上刚跑了半马。今天早上？你在说什么？对。
I've been running those. I'll tell you what, running is decent. But if you think you're in shape, try swimming. Swimming is a real test. I can't swim at all. One time I was at this like public pool with a friend of mine when I was a kid. Keep it clean. Keep it clean.
我一直在跑步。跟你说吧，跑步还算凑合。但如果你觉得你身材好，去试试游泳。游泳才是真正的考验。我根本不会游泳。有一次我小时候和一个朋友在那种公共游泳池里。注意言辞。注意言辞。
And I was in a deep end and he left me. You're in the deep end. Wait, what's under me? This feels like a fish. Sorry. Sean, Sean, yeah, I know you can't swim, you know? Cause just recently he, he emptied his pool and filled it with Skittles. No.
我在深水区，他把我扔下了。你在深水区。等等，我下面是什么？这感觉像条鱼。对不起。肖恩，肖恩，是的，我知道你不会游泳，你知道吗？因为就在最近，他把游泳池抽干，填满了彩虹糖。才没有。
Yeah. He's like, fuck it. I love, I hate swimming and I love Skittles. Wait, you know, it's so funny. I just had this image of that. And I thought that's not a bad idea. It's not. It does seem really satisfying.
对。他当时想，管他的。我爱，我讨厌游泳，我爱彩虹糖。等等，你知道，太搞笑了。我脑子里刚浮现出那个画面。我觉得这主意不错。确实不错。听起来确实挺爽的。
The slidiness of it. Just jump in and swimming with your mouth open. Sure, sure. I got to say, yeah, that I could see you doing that. And also not blaming you and being like, you know what? It makes sense. I did panic once when I was with that with my friend. When I was a kid, Tim and, and he left me and it was like, it was a lake.
那种滑溜溜的感觉。直接跳进去，张着嘴游泳。当然，当然。我得说，是的，我能想象你这么干。而且也不怪你，还会觉得，你知道吗？这很合理。我有一次确实恐慌过，跟我那个朋友一起。当我还是个孩子的时候，蒂姆，他把我留在那儿，那是个湖。
It wasn't a pool. It was a lake. And there was like this, this little floating dock that a lot of people could sit on. And so we swam out. But I didn't have enough breath or energy or, you know, whatever to swim back strength. Well, cause one of your hands was holding a cheeseburger. So it's hard to swim with one. And you were like, Tim, Tim, don't get my burger wet.
那不是泳池。是个湖。那里有那种，一小块浮动码头，很多人可以坐在上面。所以我们游了出去。但我没有足够的呼吸、体力或者，你知道的，Whatever，游回去了。好吧，因为你一只手里拿着一个芝士汉堡。所以用单手游泳很难。你当时还说，蒂姆，蒂姆，别弄湿我的汉堡。
You're getting the bun wet. I mean, one time I was at Sean's house a years ago, which I remember when I was staying there up in your little, in your garage, above your garage. And I went to the pool. You stayed at my house too. What's the matter with? Get a place.
你把面包弄湿了。我的意思是，多年前我有一次在肖恩家，我记得当时我住在你那里，在你的小地方，你车库上方。然后我去了游泳池。你也住在我家里过。有什么毛病？自己买个地方。
Get a place. Get a place. And it was, those were early days, you know, when it was fun. That's when we used to all, nobody had kids. And I could just, Sean was like, come stay. I was like, great. How's a month sound? Yeah.
买个地方。买个地方。那是，那是早期的时候，你知道的，当它还很有趣的时候。那是我们以前都在一起的时候，谁都没有孩子。我可以就，肖恩当时说，来住吧。我说，太棒了。一个月听起来怎么样？对。
And it was. And I would go in and use the pool. And Sean, I remember you being like, nobody, you're the only person who's using this pool. Yeah. Ricky, Ricky jumps in there to wash his, his code every once in a while. Right. Yeah.
确实如此。我会进去用那个泳池。肖恩，我记得你说过，没有人，你是唯一一个用这个泳池的人。对。里奇，里奇偶尔会跳进去洗洗他的衣服。对的。对。
For sure. Scott is like, Hey, let me introduce you to outside, Sean. Look at this pool. And I was like, I never go in it ever. Wait, does Ricky go in the pool or no? No, I want to try to get him to go in, but then, then, then he'd track all the water in the house. And I just don't want to.
肯定的。斯科特说，嘿，肖恩，让我给你介绍一下外面。看看这个泳池。我说我从来不用它。等等，里奇去泳池里吗？还是不去？不，我想让他进去，但是，但是，然后他会把所有水都带到屋里。我只是不想这样。
What is he? A retriever? Or is it golden doodle? He's a golden retriever slash. Once he gets in, he'll never. I know. That's why they're great swimmers. Yeah.
他是什么？寻回犬？还是金毛杜德犬？他是金毛寻回犬混血。一旦他进去，他就再也不会出来了。我知道。这就是为什么它们是优秀的游泳健将。对。
All right. I'm hearing your inhale. All right. It doesn't sound like you're in a super patient mood. And that's unfortunate because I don't know. I like to, you mean, you mean Sean. No, no, no, you, I heard your deep breath. I got nowhere to be as you know.
好了。我听到你在吸气了。好吧。听起来你现在心情不是特别有耐心。这很不幸，因为我不知道。我喜欢，你是说，你是说肖恩。不，不，不，你，我听到你深深地叹了一口气。正如你所知的，我无处可去。
I wouldn't play golf today, but I wasn't invited. Go ahead. Well, um, total respect to our next guest. I know she would agree. There's a bit of a roll the dice for starters. English is not her first language or her second actually. So ask your questions clearly and simply. I'm obviously speaking to myself here.
我今天会去打高尔夫，但我没被邀请。说吧。好吧，嗯，向我们的下一位嘉宾致以崇高的敬意。我知道她也会同意。对于初学者来说，这有点像掷骰子。英语不是她的母语，实际上也不是她的第二语言。所以请清晰、简单地提问。我显然是在自言自语。
Uh, this woman, it's fascinating. I'm telling you it's worth it. She's born in Brazil specifically in the Amazon basin. Uh, incredibly, she did not have her first experience with electricity until she left the country on her 18th birthday. No way. Yeah. She attended SMU in Dallas, Texas while living with her host family.
呃，这个女人，太迷人了。我告诉你，这绝对值得。她出生于巴西，具体是在亚马逊流域。呃，令人难以置信的是，直到她18岁生日那天离开该国之前，她从没有过接触电的经历。不会吧。是的。她在德克萨斯州达拉斯的SMU（南卫理公会大学）上学，同时寄宿在一个美国家庭。
And she became one of the first foreign born Dallas cowboy cheerleaders. She later found herself in New York city at Juilliard. No less, uh, parlaying her, uh, sideline dancing skills into an impressive string of featured parts in their world famous ballet program. She has since returned to the lush canopy of her birthplace to help bring music and dance and ideas for renewable energy to this underdeveloped and often misunderstood.
她成为了第一批外籍达拉斯牛仔啦啦队员之一。后来她发现自己来到了纽约市的茱莉亚音乐学院，毫不逊色，她将自己场边跳舞的技能转化为世界著名的芭蕾舞项目中一系列令人印象深刻的特色角色。此后，她回到了她出生地郁郁葱葱的树冠下，为这个欠发达且常被误解的地区带来音乐、舞蹈和可再生能源的理念。
Troy Aitman. Here to share her remarkable life thus far, uh, is the very shy, very nervous special guest with one of the most unique names you're ever going to hear. Welcome, Kristen, middle name, I'm not wearing, uh, last name, Wig. What? Yeah. So welcome.
特洛伊·艾特曼（Troy Aitman）。这里要分享她至今为止非凡人生的，是一位非常害羞、非常紧张的特邀嘉宾，她拥有你听过的最独特的名字之一。欢迎克里斯汀，中间名，我没戴，姓氏，威格（Wig）。什么？对。所以欢迎。
Welcome. Look at this. Yeah. Did you guys have any idea about her history? How did you know that? How did I don't talk about it? We do a lot of research, so. Oh, I mean, I was literally, I was listening just like.
欢迎。看看这个。是的。你们对她的历史有什么了解吗？你怎么知道的？我怎么会不知道，我从来不谈这个？我们做了很多研究，所以。哦，我的意思是，我简直，我刚才就像……
What? Wig, I'm sorry. I guess Jason has now gone on a morning gummy now too. Yeah. It's still pretty high off last night, um, but, uh. What the hell? Kristen, what's the first thing you did when you discovered electricity? Yeah.
什么？威格，对不起。我猜杰森现在早上也开始吃软糖了。是的。昨晚的劲儿还没过呢，嗯，但……搞什么鬼？克里斯汀，你发现电的时候做的第一件事是什么？是的。
Yeah. Uh, it just turned it on and off. Yeah. There she is. I just turned things on, left them on. That was talking about her. You guys, oh, I don't know what to say. Hi, guys.
是的。呃，就是把它打开又关上。是的，她来了。我只是把东西打开，然后开着。刚才是在说她。你们，哦，我不知道该说什么。嗨，伙计们。
Hi. Hi. It's so good to see you. I'm so happy to see you guys, and I love your podcast, and I listen to it all the time. Thank you. What are your earrings? What are those earrings?
嗨。嗨。很高兴见到你们。我很高兴见到你们，我喜欢你们的播客，我经常听。谢谢。你的耳环是什么？那些是什么耳环？
I don't know what to see because I didn't know. Super hard for the listener. I forgot I was wearing these, but they're just these little pink little, I don't know, little up side down. Magnets? They look like. They're magnets. Yeah.
我不知道该看什么，因为我不知道。对听众来说太难了。我忘了我戴着这个，但它们只是这些粉红色的、小小的，我不知道，小小的倒过来的。磁铁？它们看起来像。它们是磁铁。是的。
She's always wearing magnets. They look like prescription bottles or something. Yes. They're stuck to each other. Yes, they are. Um, well, welcome, welcome, welcome. Hi. Where do we find you today?
她总是戴着磁铁。它们看起来像处方药瓶什么的。是的。它们黏在一起了。是的，它们是。嗯，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎。嗨。今天我们在哪里能找到你？
Are we on the east? I'm in Los Angeles. Los Angeles. I'm in the, I'm on the west coast. Is that full time for you or do you still have a place in New York? No, I don't have a place in New York. Do you wish you still had a place in New York? Yeah, I do.
我们在东部吗？我在洛杉矶。洛杉矶。我在，我在西海岸。这对你来说是长期的吗，还是你在纽约仍然有个地方？不，我在纽约没有地方了。你希望你在纽约还有一个地方吗？对，我希望。
I do. You miss it? I do. I miss it. Yeah. What part? What parts? The city?
我希望。你想念它吗？我想念。我想念它。是的。哪一部分？哪些部分？这座城市？
What part do I miss? I just miss the, it's just such a different life. Your days are so different. Everything's different from. Right. You know. You're meeting people in various industries, not just one. Yeah.
我想念哪一部分？我只是想念，这真的是一种完全不同的生活。你的日子完全不同。一切都不同……对。你知道的。你在结识各行各业的人，而不只是一个行业。是的。
You're hanging out with doctors. I hung out with so many doctors. I remember when you were in SNL, Wig's dressing room was always filled with doctors. Filled with doctors and I would make them wear their scrubs because I was like, I want people to know. Oh my gosh. Free exams. Free exams only.
你和医生混在一起。我跟好多医生混在一起。我记得你在《周六夜现场》（SNL）的时候，威格的化妆室总是挤满了医生。挤满了医生，我会让他们穿上刷手服，因为我想让大家知道。哦，天哪。免费体检。仅限免费体检。
You did not, you did not, well after, so after you left the Amazon, after doubt, where did you spend most of your time growing up? Well, I lived in Lancaster, Pennsylvania when I was a very young girl. And then I, and then Rochester, New York. Yeah. No, but what's the name of the place? Oh, here it is. Hang on.
你没有，你没有，好吧，在……离开亚马逊后，在达拉斯之后，你大部分时间都在哪里长大？嗯，我很小的时候住在宾夕法尼亚州的兰开斯特。然后我，然后是纽约州罗切斯特。是的。不对，那地方叫什么名字？哦，在这里。等一下。
I got it here on my wiki page. Oh, where I was born. Canon, Canon Daiglega? Canon Daiglega. That's where I was born. Where's that? That's upstate, that's upstate New York. Yes.
我在我的维基百科页面上找到了。哦，我出生的地方。卡南代瓜（Canandaigua）？卡南代瓜。那就是我出生的地方。那是哪儿？那是纽约州北部，那是纽约州北部。是的。
It's a finger leg. Finger leg. Yeah. It's a finger leg. Yes. Well, I knew you would know that. Yes. Yeah.
是个手指湖（Finger Lake）。手指湖。是的。是个手指湖。是的。嗯，我知道你会知道的。是的。是的。
Is that where they make finger sandwiches? Yes. And just fingers. That's where all the prosthetic fingers are made. Wow. That's what my doctor friends told me. Major industry. Yeah.
那是他们做手指三明治的地方吗？是的。还有手指本身。所有的人造手指都是在那里制造的。哇。我的医生朋友就是这么告诉我的。主要产业。是的。
Yeah. Wow. Rochester, New York home of Xerox. Yes. And Kodak. And Kodak, yeah. Oh gosh. So then, so then going to the city to work was like, you, you grew up in New York.
是的。哇。纽约州罗切斯特，施乐的故乡。是的。还有柯达。还有柯达，是的。哦，天哪。所以，那么，去城里工作就像是，你，你在纽约长大。
So there. It's a long way. Well, it was, it was far. I only, I only went to New York city one time. But I mean, you were there. Like it's not like you grew up on the West coast. And then all of a sudden, you know, started working like it wasn't a culture shock. She did find her way out to Los Angeles, Sean, where she.
所以那里。路途遥远。嗯，它是，它是很远的。我只去过纽约市一次。但我的意思是，你在那儿。就像你不是在西海岸长大的一样。然后突然间，你知道的，开始工作，这并不是一种文化冲击。肖恩，她确实找到了去洛杉矶的路，在那里她……
No, no. What does it say? I've never looked away. Wikipedia. I've never looked at my page. I got stuff highlighted here. Yeah. Well, we, we, you know, we went into the, the, the groundlings program out there in Los
不，不。上面写着什么？我从来没移开过视线。维基百科。我从来没看我自己的页面。我这里有高亮标注的东西。是的。好吧，我们，我们，你知道的，我们加入了洛杉矶的笑匠剧团（Groundlings）项目，在那里，呃，我们在哪里遇到了安妮·莫莫洛（Annie Momolo）？也许吧。是的，我们遇到了。我们在那里开始了和她的友谊。哦，告诉特拉西安妮是谁。呃，克里斯汀，拜托。哦，她是我的……
Angeles where, uh, what did we meet? Annie Momolo out there. Maybe. Yes, we did. We started our friendship with her there. Oh, tell Tracy who Annie is. Uh, Kristen, please. Oh, she is my.
哦，好的。太好了。因为我正要……嗯，她是我的创作搭档。嗯，好朋友。是的。我创作生活中的伙伴。是的。
Oh, okay. Good. Cause I was about to. Um, she's my writing partner. Um, good friend. Yes. My creative life. Yeah.
她写了……你们一起写过很棒的东西。是的，我们写过。那是真的。还有。还有其他东西，那个旅行，两个辣妹。《巴布与斯塔星耀维斯塔》（Barb and Star Go to Vista Del Mar）。她来了。
She wrote that you guys wrote bright things together. Yes, we did. And that's true. And also. And other things, the trip, the two gals. Barb and star. Go to Vista. There she is.
对。对。非常，非常搞笑。非常好。嗯。好了。所以我们在洛杉矶。我们在笑匠剧团，现在我们，我们请过你的一些同事上节目，他们，呃，看起来笑匠剧团有点像是SNL的人才输送项目。
Yep. Yep. Very, very funny. Very good. Um, all right. So we're out there in Los Angeles. We're at groundlings and now we've, we've had some of your colleagues on the show and they, uh, it seems like groundlings is a bit of a feeder program for SNL.
这样说公平吗？是的。我是说，很多人都是从那里出来的。我是说，是的。那是你的，呃，SNL试镜，呃，来的地方吗，还是你离开那里之后的事？不，我当时是，我想我刚进主剧团试镜就发生了。那是一个相对无压力的，呃，情况，还是说？可能是我这辈子至今为止最紧张的一次。
Is that fair? Yeah. I mean, a lot of people have come from there. I mean, yeah. Is that where your, uh, SNL audition, uh, kind of came from or was it after you left there? No, I was, I was, I think I had just gotten into the main company when the audition happened. And was that a fairly stress-free, uh, situation or was it? Probably to this day, the most nervous I've ever been in my life.
因为我不会单口喜剧。所以一个人在舞台上，而且我从来不知道怎么从一个角色转换到另一个角色。我在想，我要转个圈吗？顺便说一句，我当时就是这么做的。很久以前我去试镜《疯狂电视》（Mad TV）时，我就是这么做的。我想我好像转圈了。所以你以为那是重置角色的方式，转个身，现在我是……
Cause I don't do stand-up. So being on stage by myself and like, I never knew how to like go from one character to another. I'm like, do I do a spin? Like, I did that by the way. I did that by the way when I auditioned for Mad TV a long time ago. I think I like spun. So you thought that was the reset on characters turn around and now I'm,
我不想让他们感到困惑。哦，看看现在是什么。嘿，你能往另一个方向转圈来把另一个角色找回来吗？因为我需要回去。你们想回去看另一个吗？是的。嗯，所以他们对怎么试镜说得不够清楚吗？他们是吗？
I didn't want them to be confused. Oh, look what is now. Hey, can you spin the other way to get the other character back? Cause I need to go back. Do you guys want to go back and see the other one? Yeah. Um, so were they not clear about how to do the audition? Were they?
就像是，你，你，呃，你有五分钟时间。请不要超时。呃，我买了一个秒表。哇。而且我，我的意思是，因为我，我真的觉得灯光会暗下来，我记得我在纽约的酒店里排练，然后计时5分03秒，得重来一次。呃，但有些人会演个10分钟左右，我当时看着……
It was like, you, you, um, you have five minutes. Please don't go over. Um, I bought a stopwatch. Wow. And I, I mean, cause I, I literally thought like the lights were going to go down and I remember being in my hotel in New York and just doing it and being like 503, gotta do it again. Um, but then some people would do it for like 10 minutes and I'd be watching like,
嘿，什么？好吧，他们没有盯着你。所以你只要，你演一系列你最喜欢的角色。嗯，他们只是说演，呃，角色和你所有的模仿。实际上我试镜了两次。哦，真的吗？我记得你在笑匠剧团待了几年才得到SNL的试镜机会？
Hey, what? Well, they didn't follow you. Yeah. So you just do a, you do a series of your favorite characters. Um, yeah, they just say do, uh, characters and any impressions you have. I auditioned twice actually. Oh really? I remember like how many years were you in the groundings before you got the audition
对于主剧团来说是几个月，就像是，我的意思是，我在学校待了很长时间。不，不，我是说你加入笑匠剧团有多久了？哦，很长时间，因为有些级别要等两年。噢。你打算对肖恩吼吗？不，肖恩最近出了几次状况，几个月前在芝加哥的舞台上有一次，无论何时他都完全不知道自己在哪里。
for us now? For the main company months, like I, I mean, I was in the school for like a long time. No, no, but I meant like how long were you a part of the groundings? Oh, a long time because some of the levels were like two year wait. Uh-oh. Are you going to yell at Sean? No, Sean's had a few incidents in the last one, one on stage in Chicago a few months ago and whenever where he's just completely doesn't know where he is.
他光顾着想他的下一个问题了。他根本没听上一个回答。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。看他多兴奋。我知道。所以几个月，主剧团只有几个月。
So busy thinking about his next question. He doesn't hear the last answer. I get so excited. I get so excited. I get so excited. Look how excited he is. I know. So a couple of months, only a couple of months on the main.
我甚至不知道是不是，呃，多久，我只知道那是我的第一场主打演出。我对时间真的很不在行。我刚想说，因为当我第一次，当你第一次在上面演目标女郎（Target Lady）的时候，那是我有史以来最喜欢的东西之一。嗯，我去看，我想那是你的第一季的第一个草稿，还是你参加的第一集，还是……这不是第一集。
I'm like, I don't even know if it was, uh, how many, I just know it was my first, uh, main show. I'm really bad with time. I was going to say because I, when I first, when you first did the target lady on that, which is one of my favorite things of all time. Um, I went, I think that was that one of your first sketches when the first season, that first episode that you were on or. It wasn't the first episode.
这是我的第一季。那是我在笑匠剧团演过的一个小品。不知为什么，我在电视上看到它时，我就在想，这看起来像是你在笑匠剧团看到的那些精彩节目之一。现在它在SNL上了。这看起来就像是一个很轻松的转移，就像是，哦，这肯定会成功的。我正在进行现场直播。我只是觉得这是世界上最好笑的事情。哦，谢谢，肖恩。
It was the, it was my first season. And that was a sketch that I did at the groundlings. I could, for some reason when I was watching it on TV, I was like, this looks like one of those brilliant things you see at groundlings. And now it's on SNL. It just looked like an easy transfer of like, Oh, of course this is going to work. I'm starting it live. I just thought it was the funniest thing in the world. Oh, thanks, Sean.
好的，我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。所以我们要回到SNL的事情上，但它显然给了你这样一个极好的、实至名归的曝光率，并将你推向了你过去几年一直在做的事情。嗯，令人难以置信。嗯，你，你这一阶段最喜欢的部分是什么？你，你，你喜欢那种从一个工作换到另一个工作的生活，而不是那种，你知道的，全年和你在一起的同一个地方、同一个家庭和同一个团队吗？
Yeah. And we will be right back. And back to the show. So we'll come back to the SNL stuff, but it clearly, it gave you such a great, well-deserved exposure and lift into what you have been doing, you know, over the last number of years. Um, incredibly. Um, are you, what's your favorite part of this phase? Do you, do you, do you like that it's sort of, you get to go from job to job to job as opposed
哦，我的意思是，是的，它们各有各的好处，你可以发现你不在的那一方的好处，你知道我的意思吗？就像在SNL一样，我，我喜欢那种日程安排，呃，我的意思是，虽然不太喜欢工作时间，但喜欢那种家庭般的氛围、例行公事，还有像在彩排和直播之间解决各种难题的过程。我喜欢，我非常、非常喜欢那个。我觉得我大脑的那一部分在我离开之后就萎缩了。
to one sort of, you know, place and family and group that you, that you're with all year or Oh, I mean, yeah, they all have their pluses and you can find the great things about the one that you're not in, you know what I mean? Like with SNL, like I, I loved having that schedule and, uh, I mean, not so much the hours, but just having the family, the routine and like just the solving of the puzzles between like dress and air. Like I loved, I love, love that. And it's a part of my brain.
但这也是让你成为一个如此优秀的作家原因。我敢打赌。是的。好吧，我，我绝对觉得即兴表演真的就是写作，特别是当你有一个和你有着如此深厚历史的搭档时。但现在，是的，有了更多的稳定性，我可以，你知道的，去看牙医了。
I feel like has atrophied since I've, since I've left. But it's what makes you such a great writer. I'll bet. Yeah. Well, I, I, I definitely feel like improv is writing really, especially when you have a partner that you have so much history with. But now like, yeah, there's more stability and I can, you know, go to the dentist. Yeah.
是的，完全正确。而且你可以拥有个人生活。所以这也很好。所以这有点像，你知道的，你没有的东西，你会想念它，但我现在非常高兴。你现在关于个人生活最喜欢的部分是什么？就像什么，你，你喜欢无所事事吗？你喜欢旅行吗？
Yeah, exactly. And you can have a personal life. And so that's nice too. So it's, it's kind of like, you know, what you don't have, you miss, but I'm, I'm very happy right now. What's your favorite part about, about, about personal life now? Like what, what do you, do you love doing nothing? Do you love traveling?
你喜欢，什么，什么，什么，你在家里最喜欢什么？什么能充实你的生活？哦，哇。太棒了。不，我们，我们这里是难以置信的记者。是什么让你动心？是什么让你动心？是什么让你动心？
Do you love, what, what, what, what, what at home is your favorite? What fills you out? Oh, wow. Nice. No, this is, we're, we're incredible journalists here. What makes you, what makes you tick? What makes you tick? What makes you tick?
是什么让你动心？是什么让你早晨起床？跟我们讲讲是什么让你动心。嗯，我现在有两个孩子了。我知道。所以这让我得起床。所以这让我得起床。这上面根本没有提到这事。
What makes you tick? What gets you out of bed in the morning? Tell us about what makes you tick. Well, I have two kids now. I know. So that gets me out of there. So that gets me out of there. That's not anywhere on this.
你知道，太搞笑了。是的，但问题是。什么样的媒体在你的主要……等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你有了两个孩子？是的。我不知道这件事。这就是我要说的事情。
You know, it's so funny. Yes, but here's the thing. What kind of media is out your main? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You've got two kids? Yes. I didn't know that. This is the thing I was going to say.
我不，就像，我只是在大概，我不知道，几周前才发现的。这是因为，你在最尊重的意义上非常有策略地在这里冒个泡，在那里冒个泡。不，你才没有。就像你，你把那部分分得那么开，真的很酷。你这么做是故意的吗？因为我也不知道你有孩子。嗯，我有，我有双胞胎。
I don't, like, I just found that out, like, I don't know, a few weeks ago. Is that on, because you, you're very strategic in the most respectful way about popping up here and popping up here. No, you don't do that. Like you're, it's very cool how you kind of keep that separate. And is that on purpose that you do that? Because I didn't know you had kids either. Well, I have, I have twins.
我通过代孕生了一个男孩和一个女孩。多大了？他们两岁半了。太棒了。太棒了。这是最棒的，你知道，每个人都说是最棒最难的。哦，不过这个年纪。我的意思是，嗯，他们正开始进入，你知道的，“不”的阶段。
I have a boy and a girl via surrogate. How old? And they are two and a half. Amazing. That's amazing. It's the best, you know, everyone says it's the best hardest. Oh, but this age. I mean, well, they are getting into, like, you know, the no phase.
好吧。那么你会，听起来你会同意我的看法，就是以前的很多东西也是，我不会说是垃圾，但它没那么好。它没那么好。我绝不会说是垃圾，但与现在相比，它没有现在这么好。那是一种不同的。是不同的。是的。
Okay. So then would you, it sounds like you would be in agreement with me that a lot of stuff before too is, I'm not going to say it's garbage, but it ain't as good. It ain't as good. I would never say it's garbage, but it's not as good as it is now in comparison to now. It's a different. It's different. Yeah.
我要站在这里，杰森总是，他只是想让别人在车里跟他搭伴。他才不想自己真的去干什么。等等，等等一下。是的。杰森，首先，抱歉，请允许我训斥一下贝特曼。那是生活的一部分，你个混蛋。是的。
I'm going to stand up here and just, Jason always, he just wants somebody to ride shotgun with him in the car. He doesn't want to have to actually fucking do anything. Wait, wait, wait a second. Yes. Jason, first of all, sorry, let me just admonish Bateman. That's part of life you dick. Yeah.
好吧。我知道。但我们，你有两个，两岁半的。我不知道你结婚了。是的。嗯，就像是一场快速的新冠疫情线上（Zoom）婚礼。你在得新冠的时候通过Zoom结婚了？不，不是，不是说他在Zoom上。
Okay. I know. But we, you have two, two and a half. I didn't know you were married. Yes. Well, it was like a quick COVID zoom marriage. You got married on zoom while you had COVID. No, it's not, not like he was on zoom.
对。我们在一起。那才奇怪呢。你认识了他，而你们从来没见过面。我们从没见过。不，但是他是。不，他是，他是娱乐圈的吗？他确实演戏。
Yeah. We were together. That would be weird. You met him and you've never met in person. And we've never met. No, but he is. No, is he, is he a show busy? He does act.
是的。而且他还写作，是个了不起的摄影师，而且他……哦，他什么都会。是吗？等一下。我们来决定这一点。我知道有很多。因为如果你不知道我有孩子。
Yes. And he writes and he's the amazing photographer and he's. Oh, he's got it all. Does he? Hang on a second. We'll decide that. I know there's a lot. Cause if you didn't know, I had kids.
我觉得这里有很多东西需要剖析。你和完美先生在一起多久了？是的。呃，六年半。哇。所以感情很稳定。感情维持得很好。太棒了。
There's, I feel like there's a lot to unpack here. You've been with Mr. Wonderful for how long? Yes. Uh, six and a half years. Wow. So it's sticking. It's sticking well. It's amazing.
是的。他很棒，而且……他作为父亲怎么样？我们不会把你说的话告诉他。他不会听这个的。嗯，他，呃，他，他太不可思议了。他太棒了。
Yeah. He's, he's great. And, uh. How is he as a dad? And we won't tell him what you say. He won't listen to this. Um, he, uh, he's, he's incredible. He's amazing.
我真的……你觉得你的盲区可能是什么？我？作为一个母亲。你会有什么……哦，作为一个母亲。比如用襁褓包孩子。我想他们现在已经不用襁褓了。
I'm truly. What do you think your blind spot might be? Me? As a mother. What could you, what could you? Oh, as a mother. Like swaddling. I guess they're out of swaddles now.
襁褓。襁褓。我告诉过你他什么都不知道。我尽力了。我在家里的时间很少。他已经离家很长时间了。他在拍戏或者打高尔夫。我的意思是，你知道的，太尴尬了。
Swaddling. Swaddling. I told you he doesn't know anything. I try. I spent a lot of time out of the house. He's been out of the house for a long time. He's shooting or playing golf. I mean, you know, it's so embarrassing.
我前几天意识到，有人问我的盲区是什么。我说盲区。显然。我的意思是，这很聪明。你知道，那就是盲区。就是你看不见的部分。我猜。有没有，有没有你小时候做过的事，你的父母恨之入骨，而你现在看到你的孩子也在做，或者类似的事情？就像你试图阻止他们，哦，等等，别学你。
I realized the other day, somebody asked me what my blind spot is. I said blind spots. Obviously. I mean, like that's smart. You know, that's what that is. It's just the parts you can't see. I guess. Is there, is there stuff that you used to do as a kid that your parents hated that you're
嗯，我的意思是，等他们长大后，我希望他们能有所不同，因为我，我想我给我的父母制造了无数次轻微的心脏病发作。做什么？只是从屋顶上跳下来。是的。是的。
like now seeing your kids do or anything like that? Like you're trying to stop them from like, oh, wait, don't catch from you. Well, I mean, when they get older, I hope they're different because I, I think I gave my parents lots of mini heart attacks. Doing what? Just jumping off the roof. Yeah. Yeah.
我想在我大约九岁父母离异之后，也许那就是……干得好，伙计们。通过，通过，好吧，是的。干得漂亮。所以等等。让我……是的。试试看。
I think after my parents got divorced when I was like nine and maybe that's. Way to go guys. Through, through, well, yeah. Nice going. So hold on. Let me just. Yeah. Try it out.
只要闭嘴，闭嘴，闭嘴。尽量控制一下。我们在做一个喜剧版本。我知道，对吧？如果你想保持这样的话，你可以把离婚那段剪掉，反正。是的。所以你，所以你九岁的时候有点叛逆。我是的。
Just shut, shut, shut. Try to keep it together. We're doing a comedy version. I know, right? You can cut the divorce thing if you want this to stay like anyway. Yeah. So you, so you were a little bit of a challenge at nine. I was.
但也不算太糟糕。我想整个高中时期，我大概惹了很多麻烦之类的事。有兄弟姐妹吗？我有一个哥哥。是的。你有个哥哥？没有。
But not terrible. I think through, through high school, I think I got in, you know, trouble a lot and stuff like that. Were there brothers and sisters? I have a brother. Yes. Did you have a problem? No.
其实没有。你是老幺。是的。我是老幺，我妈妈那边有两个继……这是在查科（Chaco）。查科。在哪儿？是的。
Not really. You were the youngest. Yes. I was the youngest and I have had two steps and steps on my mom's side and. This was in Chaco. Chaco. Where was it? Yeah.
加拿大。加拿大。但我要说我是来自查科的。我们有，因为我觉得。现在，除了那个九岁时离婚的痛苦和悲剧之外，有没有发生什么事，引导你走向喜剧？是九岁时被迫的吗？就在我发现电的时候。
Canada. Canada. But I'm going to say I was from Chaco. We have because I think. Now, did anything happen aside from the pain and tragedy of that divorce at nine that, that, that steered you towards comedy. Was it forced at nine? Right when I discovered electricity.
有没有，有没有，有什么事引导你走向喜剧？你的父母中有一个人很搞笑吗？我爸爸。是的。我爸爸非常搞笑。给我们讲讲他会做的一些搞笑的事，克里斯汀。哦，好吧，我的意思是，他就像是以一种爸爸的方式。他只是，你知道的，双关语之类的，这很有趣，我的意思是，我一直都知道他，呃……
Was there, was there, was there something that steered you towards comedy? Were one of those parents of yours funny or? My dad. Yeah. My dad is very funny. Tell us some of the funny stuff he would do, Kristen. Oh, well, I mean, he's just like in a dad way. He just like, you know, puns and like, it's just a funny, I mean, I always knew he was
我会遇到那些在他年轻时就认识他的人，每个人总是说，“哦，你爸爸，你知道的，真是个搞笑的人。”我敢打赌他挺冷幽默的吧？对。他非常冷幽默。他非常冷幽默。他把我引入了……就像劳雷尔和哈迪（Abbott and Costello）以及马丁和刘易斯（Martin and Lewis）的电影，我们就会看那些老电影，他的一百个……
like, I would meet people that knew him when he was younger and everyone just always said, oh, your dad, you know, such a funny guy. And I'll bet he was pretty dry. Right. He's very dry. He's very dry. And he introduced me to like, like Abbott and Costello and Martin and Lewis movies and like, we would just watch those old, his 100 and.
他把我介绍给阿博特太太。这简直有点……他把我当作活人介绍给他们。是的。好吧。好吧。所以……克里斯汀在跟谁说话？
He introduced me to Mrs. Abbott. This is just kind of. He introduced me to them as people. Yes. All right. All right. So, so then. Who's on Kristen?
谁在克里斯汀那儿？在哪儿呢？太蠢了。很高兴见到你。好吧。所以……所以他在笑匠剧团。你得到了SNL。你在那里。你在那个不可思议的机器里取得了不可思议的成功。然后你被抛入了这个伟大的职业生涯中。你是否必须经历一个巨大的转变，去适应在电影或电视片场的生活，这与你在SNL习惯的生活有什么不同？比如，你介意那种较慢的节奏和那种吉普赛式的漂泊生活吗？你知道的，既然你有了孩子和丈夫，你，你能经常旅行吗？
Where's on credit? Where's it? So stupid. Nice to meet you. All right. So then. So then he's very funny. All right.
我不喜欢。我的意思是，某些工作显然是必须的，但这太难了。是的。所以他们都跟你一起去吗？他们陪我去过。自从他们出生以来，我没怎么工作过，但我确实以不同的眼光看待我的工作。
So then you're out in the ground knees. You get SNL. You're there. You're in that incredible machine there and incredible success. And then you get spit out into this great career. Was there a big transition you had to make to what being on a set was like on, on a movie or on a television show versus what you were really used to on, on SNL? Like, do you mind that sort of slower pace and that kind of vagabond living and, you
我会想，它在哪里拍，拍多久，他们能去吗，他们去会好玩吗？因为我不想离开。我知道，对吧？我们都需要在伯班克街头有一部精彩的多机位情景喜剧。就在街角。如果你说，我迫不及待想离开他们，会怎么样？那就完全相反了。你现在是在模仿贝特曼吗？
know, now that you've got kids and a husband, you know, you, can you, can you travel as much? I don't like to. I mean, it's obviously necessary for certain jobs, but it's so hard. Yeah. So do they all go with you? They have gone with me. I haven't worked that much since they've been born, but I, I do look at my jobs differently.
我知道。我是。哦，我记得，克里斯汀，我记得当《伴娘》（Bridesmaids）上映的那个周末，我在亚特兰大拍《三个臭皮匠》（The Three Stooges）。全场掌声。全场掌声。我独自一人去附近的电影院看《伴娘》，我一演完就给克里斯汀发了电子邮件，我说：“哦，天哪，太搞笑了。
I'm like, where does it shoot and how long and can they go and will it be fun for them? Because I don't like being away. I know, right? We all need a nice multi-cam sitcom just down the street in Burbank. Just down the street. What if you were like, I can't get a, I can't wait to get away from them? That's just the complete opposite. Are you trying to do a Bateman right now?
太搞笑了。”你当时就说，真的吗？谢谢。就像是，没有人知道它会变成后来的那种轰动效应。然后，但是能在首映周末看到它真的很酷。我只是觉得，我觉得太棒了。哦，谢谢。它能这么好，而且你能在里面表现得这么好，真是太意料之中了，又让人惊喜。
I know. I am. Oh, I remember, Kristen, I remember I, when Bridesmaid came out that first weekend, I was in Atlanta shooting the three Stooges. Holds her applause. Holds her applause. I go see Bridesmaids across here by myself and I emailed Kristen right when I got, I was like, oh my God, it was so funny.
我的意思是，你是，我的意思是，那是那种在电视指南上看到时，你每次都会点进去看的电影，每次都是。我当时笑得前仰后合。谢谢。嗯，因为，安妮总是讲那个故事，我们在首映周末后接到一个电话，大致意思是，卧槽。抱歉。没有。
It was so funny. She's like, you know, you're like, really? Thank you. Like it was so, nobody knew that it was going to become what it did. And then, but it was so cool to have seen it on opening weekend. I just thought, I thought it was so neat. Oh, thank you. It was such, so, so unsurprising that it was so good and that you were so good.
哦，真的吗？就像是，是的。就像是，抱歉。因为它的上映规模没有完全铺开。哦，真的吗？没有。是的，我们当时想，好吧，我们尽力了。
I mean, you're, I mean, that's one of those movies that's when it's on the, when it's on the guide, you click it every single time, every time. And I'm like, I laughed so hard. Thank you. Well, cause, and Annie always tells the story that we like got a call after opening weekend, just sort of like, Holy shit. Sorry. No.
不会吧。哦，是的。哦，是的。我们没有。东海岸是不是有什么飓风之类的垃圾天气？不，我想，我想可能只是口碑传播什么的。人们后来才开始看，但在刚开始的时候，你懂的，这就好比，怎么说呢，现在不是那样了，但当时就像是，首映周末到底是怎么回事？你之前认识保罗·费格（Paul Feig）吗？保罗·费格是导演。
Oh, really? It was like, yeah. It was like, sorry. Cause it didn't fully open. Oh, really? No. Yeah. And we were like, well, we tried.
我认识，因为我在电影《同路人》（Unaccompanied Minors）里有大概两句台词，那好像是我拍的第一部电影。真的吗？那是你的第一部？是的。
No way. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. We did not. Was there like a, like a hurricane on the East coast or some garbage like that? No, I think it just, I think it was just maybe word of mouth or something. That people started seeing it later, but in the beginning you just, you know, it is when it, you're just like, what's, it's not really like that now, but it was like, what's that
不可能。噢，是的。噢，是的。我们没有。东海岸是不是有什么飓风之类的垃圾事情？不，我想它只是，我觉得可能只是靠口碑什么的。人们后来才开始看到它，但在开始时你只是，你知道的，当时的情况就是，你只是在想，什么，现在其实不太那样了，但当时就像是，那是什么
opening weekend? Did you, did you know Paul Feig before that? Paul Feig is the director. I did because I had like two lines in the movie Unaccompanied Miners, which was my first movie, I think. Was it really? That was your first? Yeah.
首周末？在此之前你认识保罗·费格吗？保罗·费格是导演。我认识，因为我在电影《无陪伴儿童》里有大约两句台词，那好像是我的第一部电影。真的吗？那是你的第一部？对。
I think so. Yes. So on SNL, Kristen, guests, guests on SNL. They run the gamut. Do they not? They do. What would, how would you, how would you describe the great guest and then how would you describe a not so great guest qualities?
我想是的。是的。所以说到 SNL，克里斯汀，嘉宾，SNL 的嘉宾。真是形形色色，对吧？确实如此。什么样的，你会怎么，你会如何形容一个极好的嘉宾，然后又会如何形容一个表现一般的嘉宾的特质呢？
Someone who, I mean, it's kind of just the op that someone who really wants to be there because, and sometimes people maybe feel like they have to or, or because they have like press or something for the most part, people want to be there. But I think just the people that are, that are game and like, yes, let's do it. And where do you want me? And, and people that don't come in and try to just like produce everything themselves. Yeah. Are there other personalities that come in and be like, no, this is how I work.
那种，我的意思是，这其实完全相反，那种真心想来的人，因为，有时人们可能会觉得他们不得不来，或者因为他们有宣传任务之类的。但绝大多数人都是想来的。不过我觉得就是那些积极配合的人，比如“太好了，我们开始吧，需要我去哪？”还有那些不会一进来就试图自己包办一切的人。是的。有没有那种一进来就说“不，这就是我的工作方式”的其他性格的人？
And that's probably counterproductive to how it runs. Yeah. And it's hard to go in and fully, you know, just be like, okay, I, I trust you. Right. And be a guest as opposed to a host, right? But when you're a cast member, a writer, it's just like your job is to take care of the host and like make them look good and, and support them, you know, which I think is good.
这可能对节目的运作适得其反。是的。而且很难一进去就完全，你知道的，就觉得“好吧，我，我相信你”。对吧？作为一个嘉宾而不是主持人，对吧？但当你是一名演员、编剧时，你的工作就是照顾好主持人，让他们看起来光彩照人，并支持他们，你知道的，我觉得这挺好的。
When we're hearing hilarious stories, Amy would come back with like, you know, host stories like this person took off their shirt. I know who she's talking about. She came in with their shirt up. Yeah. You know what I'm talking about. Wait, as a bit or like, not as a bit? Not as a bit.
当我们听到那些爆笑的故事时，艾米会回来分享，你知道的，像这样的主持人的故事：这个人把衬衫脱了。我知道她在说谁。她进来时把衬衫掀起来了。对，你知道我在说什么。等等，这是一个包袱（梗）还是说不是？不是包袱。
No, no, no. Just out of comfort. You really do get to know people when they come on the show. Also because you don't get to see actors, musicians, sports, sports people. Yeah. You don't get to see them nervous or out of their comfort zone and to have someone like, is this okay? And you're just like, oh my God, you're a freaking legend.
不，不，不。纯粹是为了舒服。当你上这个节目时，你确实能真正了解人们。也是因为你平时看不到演员、音乐人、体育明星。是的。你见不到他们紧张或局促不安的样子，而当有人问“这样可以吗？”时，你只会觉得“天哪，你可是个传奇人物啊”。
Are you kidding? I'm a mess. Yeah. It's, but it's, it's so cool because they, they do, you, you see this, this vulnerability, it's like a transformation through, you know, Monday through Saturday, and they're just like, oh my God, like I just had to let go, you know. Did you ever have one of those moments where you go, holy shit, like where you kind of were in yourself and you were just feeling it and you were just for the first time you
你在开玩笑吗？我简直一团糟。是的。这太酷了，因为他们确实，你会看到这种脆弱感，就像是通过（周一到周六的）排练完成了一次蜕变，他们会感叹“天哪，我刚刚不得不卸下防备，你知道的”。你有没有过这样的时刻，你心想“卧槽”，就是那种你完全沉浸其中，用心感受，并且第一次你
kind of go like, I can't believe I'm doing this scene with so and so and then it's going like that. Did you have every show for seven years? Yes. And I think that's like, it's, it truly is like the best. It is like the best job. If you're going to do something like that and you're living in New York and I feel like, and I always said like the moment, because you know how it is there.
会有种“我简直不敢相信自己正在和某某某演这场戏，而且进展得如此顺利”的感觉。你每一集都有这种感觉吗？整整七年都有。是的。而且我觉得这就像是，它真的是最好的工作。如果你要做这样的事情，而且你住在纽约，我觉得，我总是说，因为你了解那里的情况。
It's like a, it's a different culture and you're always, you never know what the show is going to be. You don't quite feel like settled. And I always said like the moment I feel comfortable here is like the moment that I should leave. Yeah. So it was never lost on you, all these cool people that were coming through there and these musicians. Cause every week you'd be like, oh my God.
这就像是一种不同的文化，你总是，你永远不知道这期节目会变成什么样。你从未真正感到尘埃落定。我总是说，我在这里感到舒适的那一刻，就是我应该离开的时候。是的。所以你从来没有忘记过，所有这些通过这里的大牌明星和这些音乐人。因为每周你都会觉得“哦，天哪”。
I mean, well, you know, you would do there and like you'd just be like, wait, you'd come off from a sketch and Lawrence, like the Steven Spielberg is watching the show. I was like, hello. And then you're changing and you're just like, where, what is happening? What it always, what always struck me was on Wednesday, especially on Wednesdays after read through like going and meeting up with you guys or whatever in going for a drink and just how it didn't matter how long you were there. And it didn't matter if, if, you know, where you were in terms of seniority on the show
我的意思是，你知道的，你在那儿的时候，你会觉得，等一下，你刚演完一个短剧下来，劳伦斯，就像史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格在看这个节目。我会想：天哪。然后你在换衣服，脑子里只想：这是在哪儿，发生什么了？最让我震撼的是，在周三，特别是周三的通读剧本之后，去和你们会合或者干别的，去喝一杯，不管你在那儿待了多久，这都是一样的。而且无论你在节目的资历排行中处于什么位置，
too, based on how long you'd been doing the show, everybody, there was always that tension of like, fuck that thing. It didn't go great. It's not going to get picked or that thing didn't get picked. And I'm kind of pissed off and I kind of like, I've had it. I didn't have a great show last week. I wish this thing had gone this week. And it always struck me how it just never stops.
不管你在这个节目干了多久，每个人心中总是有一种紧迫感：“操，那个东西演砸了，它肯定不会被选中”或者“那个没被选中，我有点不爽，我真是受够了。我上周的表现不够好，我希望这个东西这周能上。”最让我震惊的是，这种感觉永远不会停止。
It never goes away. No matter who you are. Yeah. Yeah. It's a good, right? It keeps you working hard. You never take anything for granted. Right?
它永远不会消失。不管你是谁。是的。没错，对吧？它让你保持努力工作。你永远不会把任何事视为理所当然，对吧？
There's like a healthy competition there. Well, I don't, I don't even know if like, we didn't really have like a super competitive group when I was there. But it was really, I mean, baked into it is only the best sketches make it that week. Yeah. And if you're, if that sketch goes, maybe this one won't because maybe you, maybe they're similar or maybe, but it's like, oh, maybe you can do it another time. I don't know.
那里有一种健康的竞争氛围。嗯，我甚至不知道，当我们那儿的时候，我们是不是真的有一个超级竞争的群体。但确实，内嵌的机制就是只有最好的短剧才能在那个星期播出。是的。如果那个短剧播出了，也许这个就不会播，因为也许你们的题材撞了，或者也许，但这就变成了“哦，也许你可以在其他时候演”。我不知道。
Like also if something doesn't work, like I don't want to do it on the show. I'd rather not be in stuff. Now, do you see, do you see either one of those two twins of yours going into the, is anyone, either one of them seem funny or prone to the spotlight? If anyone, my daughter, but I, it's probably too early to tell that she's, she does some funny things. Yes. Yeah.
而且如果有些东西效果不好，我也不想在节目里演。我宁愿不参演那些东西。现在，你觉得你的那对双胞胎里，有没有谁会进入，有没有人看起来挺搞笑或者有聚光灯体质的？如果要说的话，我女儿有点这方面的倾向，但现在下结论还太早，她确实会做一些搞笑的事情。是的。是的。
She does some, some bits. And I, I try sometimes with like voices and sometimes they're just like, what, to try to get her going. Yeah. But they don't think I'm funny. All right. Don't you have to like, hey, you guys with kids, don't you have to like apply for like preschool like now?
她会抖一些包袱。有时候我也会尝试模仿各种声音来逗她，有时候他们只是“啊？”想看看能不能调动她的积极性。是的。但他们觉得我一点都不好笑。好吧。你们这些有孩子的，难道不需要现在就去申请幼儿园之类的吗？
Like, is it hard to get into schools or something? You have to start now. It's a pain in the ass. Are you starting to sweat that Kristen or that still like a year away looking for preschools and kindergartens and. I mean, they're in, they're in like a little preschool now, which I love. It's amazing. I haven't really thought about it.
比如，现在很难进学校吗？你现在就得开始。这可真是个令人头疼的麻烦。克里斯汀，你开始为这事操心了吗？还是说找幼儿园和小学这事儿对你来说还是一年以后才需要考虑的？我的意思是，他们现在在一个小型的幼儿园里，我挺喜欢的。太棒了。我还没怎么想过这事儿。
Yeah. It's, it starts to get stressful. I know, I guess I should, but like part of me is just like. No, I think fucking is the best way to go and just kind of roll the dice. Yeah. It's such a stress. I just see so many people worried about it. And I don't know.
是的。这开始变得有压力了。我知道，我想我是该操心了，但我的内心深处却在想……不，我觉得顺其自然、听天由命才是最好的办法。是的。这压力太大了。我看到太多人为此操心了。我不知道。
Are you enjoying any, any, any shows with your kids right now that are particularly, because I used to love watching kids shows with my kids when they were young enough to watch stuff. I was interested. Now they're watching, you know, really, they're watching a lot of stuff. Euphoria. Exactly. I can't, I can't.
你现在有没有和你的孩子们一起看什么特别喜欢的节目？因为我以前很喜欢在孩子们还小、能看懂的时候陪他们看儿童节目。那些是我感兴趣的。现在他们在看，你知道的，他们看很多《亢奋》（Euphoria）。没错。我真的看不了。
Yeah. No joke. My kids love Euphoria. Mostly just for the music though, right? Yeah. Sometimes I just turn off the sound and just let them watch what's happening. Are you, are you watching anything with them that you particularly like or anything with Mr. Wonderful that you, that you really like, like comedy or drama?
真的不带开玩笑的。我的孩子们超爱《亢奋》。不过主要还是为了听音乐吧？是的。有时候我直接把声音关掉，让他们看画面就行了。你有没有和他们一起看什么你特别喜欢的节目，或者有什么和“美男子”一起看的、你们俩都特别喜欢的，比如喜剧或剧情片？
Mr. Wonderful is going to love this. What's his name? Avi. His name's Avi. Avi. Is it short for obvious? Avi. Avi.
美男子听到这个肯定会笑死。他叫什么名字？阿维（Avi）。他叫阿维。Avi。是“显而易见”（Obvious）的缩写吗？
You guys, this is all free. This is my husband, Avi. And now a word from our sponsor. And now back to the show. Are you not a fan of devices or media for children? Not right now. Not right now. Finger painting and stuff like that?
伙计们，这些都是免费的。这是我丈夫阿维。现在插播一条广告。现在我们回到节目中。你难道不喜欢给孩子们玩电子设备或看媒体内容吗？现在不给。现在不给。玩手指画之类的吗？
I mean, I don't want anything to be like, no, you could never because then we'll, you know, like, like with sugar, you hear about people that never give their kids sugar and then they like hide food in their room. Right. Yeah. Not me. But yeah, not yet. We show them like, we just kind of started showing them videos of like trains.
我的意思是，我不想把事情搞得太绝对，说什么“不，绝对不行”，因为那样的话，你知道的，就像糖果一样，你听说过有些家长从不给孩子吃糖，结果孩子们把食物藏在房间里。对。是的。我可不会这样。不过，是的，目前还没有。我们给他们看，我们最近才开始给他们看一些关于火车的视频。
It's just like, it's literally just like different trains. Sure. Good for you. There's no like puppets or anything. It's just like. Isn't it kind of fun though when you have kids that small, isn't it great excuse to do crafts? I love doing crafts. Yes.
就是那种，字面意思就是各种各样的火车。那挺好的。没有什么木偶戏之类的。就是纯粹的。当你的孩子那么小的时候，这难道不是一个做手工的好借口吗？我太喜欢做手工了。是的。
Side note, Sean, can I hire you this summer to be a counselor over at my house because I've got, I've got three kids and a step. I like doing crafts and stuff. I love crafts. Me too. It's such a great excuse. Oh God, I'd love to see you do some crafts. Do you have a craft room, Sean?
顺便问一句，肖恩，这个夏天我能雇你来我家当辅导员吗？因为我有三个孩子和一个继子。我喜欢做手工之类的。我太爱做手工了。我也是。这真是一个绝佳的借口。哦天哪，我很想看你做手工。肖恩，你有一个手工房吗？
Do you have like a bunch of glue and shit around? No, but that's like a dream of mine. What a bunch of glue. Can't you tell? Do you? But wait, I am curious. Do you have a guilty pleasure with Avi? Is it any sort of reality shows or?
你家里到处都是胶水什么的吗？没有，但这绝对是我的梦想。到处都是胶水。难道你看不出来吗？你有吗？不过等等，我很好奇。你和阿维有什么不可告人的小爱好吗？比如看什么真人秀之类的？
I love reality shows. He does not. He does not. What are you chewing up right now? I'm a Bravo girl. Oh, you are? Yeah. Oh my God.
我超爱真人秀。他可不爱看。他一点都不看。你现在最沉迷于看什么？我是 Bravo 电视台的忠实粉丝。哦，是吗？是的。天哪。
You just made their goddamn day. Everybody at Bravo. This clip is going to be played around the office. She's a Bravo girl. You know? They know. All of it. Do they know?
你刚才可让他们高兴坏了。Bravo 的所有人。这段剪辑肯定会在他们办公室里到处播放。她是个 Bravo 粉丝。你知道吗？他们知道。全都知道。他们知道吗？
Have you gone on there and done some with Andy? Yes. What's his name? Andy Cohen, yes. He's done Andy's. What about Million Dollar Listing? Andy's a hoot. I do watch that one.
你有没有上过那个节目，和安迪一起录过？去过。他叫什么名字？安迪·科恩（Andy Cohen），对。她上过安迪的节目。那《百万美元房产中介》（Million Dollar Listing）呢？安迪是个怪咖。那个节目我确实看。
That one seems a little more scripted for me. Yeah, yeah, it is. But that's what I kind of like about it. I like it more. I don't watch that one. Sean, shots fired by Wig. Wait, why are you like a producer? No, no.
对我来说，那个节目看起来有点太剧本化了。对，对，确实是。但这也是我喜欢它的原因。我更喜欢这种。我不看那个。肖恩，威伊（Wig）向你开炮了。等等，你这是在当制作人吗？不，不。
I love that you watch those shows. I know. I like the thing I like about Million Dollar Listing is that it's a little scripted. It's like a little awkward. It is. It is. I mean, I watch it. So there's got to be something.
我喜欢你看这些节目。我知道。我喜欢《百万美元房产中介》的一点就是它有点剧本化。感觉有点尴尬。确实是。我是说，我看过。所以肯定有吸引人的地方。
I love that you watch it. What's your favorite group of housewives? Tough, tough shows. I love Potomac. Oh, I've not done Potomac yet. And I love Beverly Hills. Uh-huh. Yeah.
我太喜欢你看这个了。你最喜欢哪个“娇妻”（Housewives）系列？这些都是硬核节目。我喜欢《波托马克娇妻》（Potomac）。哦，我还没看过《波托马克》。我还喜欢《比佛利山庄娇妻》（Beverly Hills）。嗯哼。是的。
Jersey and Atlanta. Oh, bless. So you're not, you're killing a lot of Jays. Yes, I do. Do you really? Yes. I missed it. What'd you say?
《新泽西》和《亚特兰大》。哦，天哪。所以你看了很多以 J 开头的节目。是的，没错。真的吗？是的。我漏掉了。你刚才说什么？
I watched all of it. I think that she really watches them. She says she does. Oh, yeah. I love it. I think it's, it's like, I think when you do what we do sometimes, you cannot get as lost as we used to get when we watched movies and TV. And like, sometimes you're like, oh, did they shoot this at night?
我都看了。我觉得她是真的在看。她说她看了。哦，是的。我太喜欢了。我觉得，有时候当你从事我们这行时，你很难像以前看电影和电视那样完全沉浸其中。有时候你会想：“哦，他们这是在晚上拍的吗？”
You know, like you can't, you kind of like can't, you know what I mean? And like, for something about reality, I turned my brain off. And I just, You know, it'd be such a great idea for you is to do like a parody movie or TV show like, like that. It'd be such a great idea for you. That would be good. Yeah.
你知道的，你就好像无法，你知道我的意思吗？而关于真人秀的某些东西，能让我的大脑彻底放空。我只想……你知道的，对你来说一个绝佳的主意就是拍一部像那样的恶搞电影或电视节目。这对你来说绝对是个绝佳的主意。那倒挺不错的。是的。
Wait, didn't Stiller did one of those? Any real life, I think? Wasn't that, was that what it was called? Long, long time ago? Or no, he loved real life that Charles Groden did way, way, way back when, I think. Anyway, fascinating story. The story is really gripping. It's out of the solid.
等等，斯蒂勒（Stiller）不是拍过那种吗？任何真实生活类的，我想？那不就是那个叫什么来着？很久很久以前的？还是说，他喜欢查理·格鲁登（Charles Groden）很久很久以前拍的那个《真实生活》？不管怎样，这是一个引人入胜的故事。这个故事真的很抓人。太经典了。
We need stuff to trim. I like to give stuff to trim. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What, what kind of stuff, you've done so many different things. What do you, what now is the thing that will get you to leave home? Yeah. And stop watching America. Yeah.
我们需要剪掉一些内容。我喜欢提供一些可以剪掉的料。等等，等等，等等，等等。什么样的话题，你做过这么多不同的事情。你现在觉得有什么事能让你离开家？是的。不再看美国真人秀。是的。
Like what's going to get you out of the house to go and do? What's the thing that you go like, I really want to do this? Aside from a fire. A fire. Oh, yes. Yeah. Well, I'm about to start shooting something in LA, a show. We're making news right now.
比如什么事能让你走出家门去工作？有什么事会让你觉得“我真的很想做这个”？除了发生火灾。火灾。哦，是的。好吧，我马上要在洛杉矶开拍一部新剧。我们正在创造新闻呢。
What is it? Yes. It's, it's a show based on the book Mr. and Mrs. American Pie. It takes place in 1969 in Palm Beach about this woman who's a little, it's very like slim air and sort of vibe of the show. This woman who's a little unhinged. She's trying to like get into the high society of Palm Beach. The title's in flux.
是什么？是的。这是一部根据小说《棕榈滩黑帮》（Mr. and Mrs. American Pie）改编的剧。故事背景设定在 1969 年的棕榈滩，讲述了一个有点精神崩溃的女人。这部剧很有上流社会的氛围。这个女人有点精神失常。她试图挤进棕榈滩的上流社会。剧名还没最终敲定。
So I'm not sure what I can say. Comedy or drama. It's comedy. It's like a dark comedy. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm really excited. It's shooting in LA.
所以我不太确定我能透露多少。是喜剧还是剧情片？是喜剧。有点像黑色幽默。是的。是的。但我真的很兴奋。在洛杉矶拍摄。
That's so great. Who's, who's doing that with, who's jumping on that with you? Oh, like cast wise. Yeah. Laura Dern. Love. Incredible. Alison Janney.
太棒了。谁，谁和你一起演？哦，演员阵容方面。是的。劳拉·邓恩（Laura Dern）。太棒了。难以置信。艾莉森·珍妮（Alison Janney）。
Amazing. Also incredible. Love her. I'm not sure who else is official. Well, you don't need anybody else. You need us to help close any deals. I mean, we can get on with, we can get on with BA today and close this shit by. Right now.
惊艳。同样难以置信。我太喜欢她了。我不确定还有谁是官方确定的。好吧，你不需要其他人了。你需要我们帮你搞定任何合同吗？我的意思是，我们现在就可以联系商务事务部门（BA），把这事儿给敲定。就在现在。
Alice is tough to close. Alison, is that what it is? Or is Laura being this? No, no, they're done. They're done. Laura is a producer. Hey, call, call Laura up and walk and go, Hey, regarding your deal. How you done?
爱丽丝（Alice）的合同很难谈下来。艾莉森，是这样吗？还是劳拉在……不，不，他们已经谈妥了。谈妥了。劳拉是制片人。嘿，打电话给劳拉，走过去说：“嘿，关于你的合同。谈得怎么样了？”
Nice. That's pretty good. That's so good. Hey, you're Siri, Siri, co-apple business affairs. One second guys. I'm going to fucking close this shit. There's no, there's no shooting in Florida. Well, no, we will.
不错。这主意挺好。太棒了。嘿，你是 Siri，苹果商务事务部的 Siri。等一下，伙计们。我要把这事给谈下来。没有，没有在佛罗里达拍摄。好吧，不，我们会拍的。
I think there's a little bit. I think there's a little bit, but it's mostly here. How'd you get them to shoot in Los Angeles? Tracy, to shoot in Los Angeles is very expensive, especially when you consider there's huge tax incentives to shoot in a lot of other states. So how did you just say, listen, I got two kids. I don't want to leave and a husband that is obvi, really great. Yeah, kind of.
我觉得会有一小部分。我觉得会有一点，但主要还是在这里。你是怎么让他们在洛杉矶拍的？特雷西，在洛杉矶拍戏非常贵，尤其是考虑到在很多其他州拍戏有巨额的税收优惠。所以你是怎么跟他们说“听着，我有两个孩子，我不想离开，还有一个非常棒的丈夫阿维”的？对，差不多吧。
Good for you. I just, I needed to be here and they were game. So yeah. Hey, let me ask you this, Chris. Did you, is there anything else you ever wanted to do? Like if you weren't doing this, like any other kind of? There's a lot of things. Tell me, tell me.
真为你高兴。我只是，我需要留在这里，他们也很配合。所以，是的。嘿，让我问你这个，克里斯。你有没有，还有没有其他你想做的事？比如如果不做这个，还有什么其他类型的？有很多事情。告诉我，告诉我。
I mean, there's, I would love to direct maybe someday. Let's talk about that. Yeah. So I would love to talk to you about that. I, I don't know. Just outside of the business. Oh yeah. I would love to.
我的意思是，如果有机会，我以后可能会想当导演。我们来聊聊这个。是的。所以我很想和你聊聊这个。我不知道。除了演艺圈之外。哦，是的。我很想。
I mean, I majored in art and I love to paint and draw and I love writing music and I. What? I've shone over for some crafts. And I love doing crafts. You need to get over to Sean's house and split the day. Half of the arts and crafts and half with the music. There you go. So the directing thing is something that you really want to do because.
我的主修专业是艺术，我喜欢画画，我也喜欢写歌，而且我。什么？我来找肖恩一起做手工了。而且我喜欢做手工。你需要去肖恩家，把一天劈成两半。一半时间搞艺术和手工，另一半时间搞音乐。这就对了。所以当导演是你真正想做的事，因为。
I've, I've always wanted to do it. I, it doesn't feel like it's the right time right now because I know it's so time consuming and I wouldn't find like the right thing. But I think later in my life, I would love, I would love to, to do that. Yeah. This thing that you're doing with Apple, it is a limited series or ongoing or a movie. We'll see if they like it. It's supposed to be for a few years.
我一直都很想做。现在感觉还不是好时机，因为我知道这太耗时间了，而且我可能找不到合适的项目。但我觉得在我生命的后期，我很乐意，我很乐意去尝试。是的。你和苹果合作的这个项目，是一部限定剧、长剧还是一部电影？我们看看他们是否喜欢。暂定是拍好几年。
But you know, we have to see how it goes. But hopefully. Are you writing, are you writing as well? I'm not. No, I'm not. Okay. But you're in a position where you can not co-direct but be talking. You have a seat at the table with the director.
但你知道的，我们得看情况进展如何。不过希望如此。你在写剧本吗？我没有。不，我没有。好吧。但你现在处于这样一个位置：你不仅可以联合执导，还可以参与讨论。在导演面前，你有一席之地。
You're, you're, you're the boss. Yeah. Ish. I mean. You never call yourself that. Let us do it. I would never call myself that. Yeah.
你，你，你是老大。差不多吧。我的意思是。你可千万别这么叫自己。让我们来叫吧。我绝不会这么叫自己。是的。
Because we have such a good team people. And also Laura is, is a, is a producer as well. Yes. Yes. She, her production company, she's the one that, that brought me the, brought me into it and asked me to do it. So yeah, she's, she's the boss. Well, you three guys are so, have you three guys worked together before or know each other?
因为我们有一个非常棒的团队。而且劳拉也是一名制片人。是的。是的。她，她的制作公司，她是那个把我带进这个项目、邀请我出演的人。所以，是的，她才是老大。你们这三个人太厉害了，你们三个以前合作过或者认识吗？
Because. Oh, I did work with Laura for a second when I did a, I did a few episodes of last man on earth and she, she did a couple and we were in it together. I would put you three together in a second, just based on knowing the three of you, knowing that that would be, you guys would, you could, you guys could travel together, you know, let alone work together. Yeah. That's a great match.
因为……哦，我跟劳拉短暂合作过，当时我客串了几集《最后一个男人》（Last Man on Earth），她也客串了几集，我们一起演过。基于我对你们三个的了解，我觉得你们三个随时都可以凑到一块儿，光是知道你们的为人就知道，你们绝对能一块儿去旅行，更不用说工作了。是的。这真是绝配。
I'm so excited. Wait. And McGroober's came out, right? The TV series. Yes. Yeah. It's one of the funniest things. We love some Will Forte.
我太兴奋了。等等。《麦克格鲁伯》（MacGruber）播出了吧？电视剧版。是的。是的。这是最搞笑的事情之一。我们太喜欢威尔·福特（Will Forte）了。
Oh God. I know I listened to Will on your, I listened. He's just, I mean, all you can do is just kind of breathe out when you talk about Will. Yes. And his writing too. I know. I mean. I love watching him work act, just be in the world.
天哪。我知道我在你的节目里听过威尔的采访，我听了。他简直就是，我的意思是，每当你提起威尔时，你只能长舒一口气。是的。还有他的写作也是。我知道。我的意思是。我喜欢看他表演，看他在那个世界里演戏。
He's just the best. Wig, Wig and Forte and I did that brother song and years. Yeah. You had years of guys. That was like my first like. Yeah. Movie that I had like. We laughed.
他绝对是最好的。威伊、福特和我多年前一起录过那首兄弟之歌。是的。你们有好多年的交情了。那可以说是我的第一部……是的。我参与的有分量的电影。我们笑了。
Remember how much we laughed doing that? Oh my God. Wig used to do this bit. Wig used to do this bit. It was like, to the music of one of those like toy, do you remember for like little girls like toys? And it was like, my first alcohol. Do you remember that?
还记得我们当时笑得有多厉害吗？天哪。威伊以前经常表演这个小段子。威伊以前经常演这个。它是伴着那种玩具音乐的节奏，你还记得像是给小女孩玩的玩具吗？歌词大概是：“我的第一口酒精”。你还记得吗？
Yes. I just remember we would do the dumbest thing. And I don't know if this is going to translate, but Will and I would just be like, oh my God. I'm so thirsty. I just need something to drink. I'm so thirsty. Oh, hold on.
记得。我只记得我们当时在做最蠢的事情。我不知道这能不能翻译出来，但我和威尔总是会说：“哦天哪，我太渴了，我就是想喝点东西。我太渴了。哦，等等。哦。”
Oh. Like we would just take the tiniest bit or say I'm so starving and we'd get to food and just take the tiniest little bit. A little bustle. And it was the dumbest. We would do it all the time. I loved it like that. It was so stupid.
就像我们只是喝一小口，或者说“我快饿死了”，然后走到食物面前，只吃那么一小口。一小口。这简直蠢透了。我们经常这么干。我超喜欢那种感觉。太蠢了。
But Will, you're one of those people whenever I see or whenever I saw it like SNL, like you were just such a funny, like we would just laugh seeing each other and you would just always such a light. I don't get it. I don't see that. I agree. I agree. I agree.
但威尔，你就是那种人，每当我看到你，或者每当我在 SNL 看到你的时候，你总是那么幽默，我们只要看到对方就会忍不住笑，而且你总是像一道光。我不明白。我看不出来。我同意。我同意。我同意。
I feel this. By the way, I feel the same way about you. Every time I see you, I just want to play. No. That I, yeah. That I understand. That makes sense. Wig, who makes you laugh in your life rather than your kids and Avi, like day to day like
顺便说一句，我对你也有同感。每次我看到你，我都只想和你一起玩。不。这个，是的。我能理解。这说得通。威伊，除了你的孩子和阿维之外，在日常生活中，谁能让你捧腹大笑？比如你的朋友。日常生活中。你打电话给谁。你知道的，安妮。对我来说，安妮·莫莫洛（Annie Momolo）是这世上最搞笑的人之一。快告诉我你们俩在密谋什么新项目。我们确实在。我们正在。
your friend. Day to day. You call him. You know, Annie. Annie Momolo to me is just one of the funniest people that's ever walked the Earth. Tell me you guys are cooking something up. We are. We are.
我们目前正在为迪士尼写一部关于灰姑娘的邪恶继姐的电影。哦，太棒了！是的。哦，哇。我们在写这个。这是我们第一次尝试。我们就像是在写点东西。然后——
We're writing a movie for Disney right now about the evil stepsisters Cinderella. Oh, that's great. Yeah. Oh, wow. We're writing that. This is our first time. We're just like writing something. And then like-
伙计们，我们又爆出大新闻了。这些都是没人知道的事情。我想。不，不。我们在独家爆料。不，大家还不知道。好吧，告诉我们这些聪明的听众吧。是的。你们什么时候能写完？那是真人版还是动画版？那是真人音乐剧，所以这有点像是一片未知的领域。
We just made more news guys. This is all this stuff no one knows. I think. No, no. We're breaking news. No, people don't know. Okay, good to our smart listeners. Yes. When are you gonna be done? Is that live-action or is it animated? It's live-action musical, so it's like kind of uncharted territory
我的意思是，你看到肖恩刚才往下看，当你说是音乐剧时，他抬头看着你……我们什么时候能看到这个作品？好吧，我的意思是，我们目前正处于剧本重写阶段，所以还非常早，但希望能在接下来的几年里……这是你每天都和她一起创作的项目吗？比如你今天写了什么，或者你今天做了什么？今天我们可能应该写点。我们刚收到反馈意见，你知道的，有时候很难静下心来坐在电脑前。嗯，那你呢？你今天有什么计划？你今天打算怎么过？洛杉矶现在是 10点55 分。
I mean, did you see Sean's face when he was looking down and you said musical and he looked up When's that what when do we get to when do we get to enjoy that? Well, I mean worst we were just in like rewrite phase right now, so it's very beginning, but hopefully in the next couple years Is that something that you work on every single day with her like what do you write today or what do you do today today? We probably should We just got notes, you know, it's hard to it's hard to get to the computer sometimes Um, but what do you got? What do you got? What do you got planned today? What how you got it's now 1055 in Los Angeles? Well, my kids will be home from their little school at one o'clock
好吧，我的孩子们一点钟就会从他们的小学校放学回家。所以在他们回家之前，我能享受一段安静美好的时光，这挺不错的。我的意思是，我爱他们。当然，当然。是的。是的。是的。那是中间的两个小时。是的，我其实没有两集的……我其实没什么计划。你不会在中间这段时间看《娇妻》吧？我不喜欢在白天看电视，我不是那种白天看电视的人。所以你有一条绝不跨越的底线。是的。而且我需要留点盼头到晚上看，你知道的，我喜欢把孩子们哄睡着之后，心想：“《波托马克》！这些女士今晚又整出什么幺蛾子了？”因为这非常真实。嘿，那你呢？你接下来的两个小时打算干嘛？你知道你是个混蛋，因为你知道——
So I'll just have a nice quiet house until they get home, which is nice. I mean, I love them Sure, sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's two hours between. Yeah, I don't really have a two episodes I don't really have a plan. You're not gonna watch housewives between. I don't like to watch during the day I'm not like a TV watcher during the day. So you've got a line over which you will not cross. Yeah I'm gonna plus I need something at night to look forward to you know, like I like putting the kids down and being like Potomac. What are these ladies getting into tonight? This is because it's very real. Hey, well, what are you gonna? Well, what are you gonna do for the next two hours? You know what you're a dick because you know that
为什么？因为你没被邀请去打高尔夫。好吧，我今天没被邀请去打高尔夫。我刚回到镇上，我已经离开几个月了。我周三才刚回来，这个混蛋……我有个好主意。你为什么不回练习场去呢？好吧？是的，你为什么不回去再多练习练习呢？你知道我要做什么吗？我要去健身房锻炼。我的拳击馆就在这儿。哦，那是“格斗训练营”（Fight Camp），对吧？也就是格斗训练营。但我练习的方式很特别，你不需要去那种喧闹的健身房。我反其道而行之，调暗灯光，然后一边打拳一边放古典音乐。我可不是说摄像头刚好转过拐角就能拍到我。
What cuz you weren't invited to golf well, I wasn't invited to play golf today. I just got back in town I've been gone for a few months. I just got back Wednesday in this a-hole. I got a good idea Why don't you go back to the range? Okay? Yeah, don't you go back and practice a little bit more? You know what what I am gonna do is I'm gonna go I'm gonna work out I got my boxing gym right here. Oh, that's fight camp right fight camp But I do it in a way like you don't need to go into a Philly I go against the I go against the green and it kind of like low light and then you I play like classical music as I box I don't mean the camera just comes around the corner. It finds me there
我是说……你上身穿着衣服还是光着膀子？穿着袖子还是光着胳膊？你确定吗？不，当然穿着衣服，但没穿衬衣。是的。我肯定已经经历过这些了。嘿，特雷西，顺便说一句，特雷西大约两小时后就要到了。是吗？等等，等等，我姐姐要来。
I mean Just you got it. You got a top on or top off sleeves on sleeves off. What are you sure? No, sure, but you do wear sleeves. I do wear sleeves, but no shirt. Yeah I must have already gone through this Hey Tracy by the way, Tracy's gonna be here in like two hours. Is that right? Yeah, wait wait wait my sister's coming This is news. Is she's gonna stay with you or are you not gonna put her in the hotel at the neighbor's shed the neighbor's Not even your shit All right, all right Kristen
这也是个大新闻。她是要跟你住一起，还是你打算把她安排在酒店或者邻居的棚子里？邻居的棚子。连你的棚子都不是。好吧，好吧，克里斯汀。
Kristen it's been lovely Will's taking way too much of your time. We love you. I love you guys This was so fun. We love We love Avi and we love your children. Thank you. So I love your earrings. We love the time you spent with us Yes Thank you. I hope you get it I hope you really savor your next two hours of just mellow and peace at the house. I'm gonna savor it I'm happy. Just get like one of those like international collection of coffee and just sit out in your back Oh, just with a savor cozy cup scarf and the 90 degree weather
克里斯汀，今天聊得很开心。威尔占用了你太多时间了。我们爱你。我们爱你。太有趣了。我们爱阿维，也爱你的孩子们。谢谢。我也爱你的耳环。谢谢你们陪我们度过这段时光。是的。谢谢。希望你能好好享受接下来的两个小时，在家里享受片刻的安宁与平静。我会好好享受的。去找一杯那种国际精选咖啡，坐在后院里……哦，捧着一杯舒适的咖啡，围着围巾，外面可是 90 度的高温呢。
All right, big love Your I love your podcast you guys are all amazing and thanks for having me. We love you. You're a mega talent for being here Hey, yeah, you're a mega talent, huh? Yes, slam it I I love her. I love her a lot. Yeah, we didn't talk about I did I did I did two films with her did extract that Mike Judge film and then also Paul About the alien with the side of tag. So you've known her for a while. I have I just real crazy about her Yeah, I don't see her enough, but Amanda chats with her every once in a while. Yeah
好了，大大的爱。我爱你们的播客，你们太棒了，谢谢你们邀请我。我们爱你。你是个超级天才，谢谢你能来。嘿，是的，你是个超级天才，对吧？没错，太棒了！我太喜欢她了。我超级喜欢她。是的，我们之前没聊过……我拍过她演的两部电影，一部是迈克·怀特的《Extract》，另一部是保罗·雷贾伊（Paul Reiser）关于那个外星人的电影。所以你认识她很久了。是的，我简直为她着迷。是的，我见她不够多，不过阿曼达每隔一段时间会和她聊聊天。是的。
Very jealous. She's um, so I mean, she's one of the funniest of all time, but you're right She does keep a very low profile. That is admirable. I would like to see I'd like to see more of her on Screen at least. Yeah, she's made. She's so funny always Wig just always funny and I mean that that like we were saying that every time I see her We just I just want to play. I just want to yeah I know goof around and do a bit and fuck one of those people that was born to do what she's doing Yeah, I'm the best born-to-bit anyway
太让人嫉妒了。她，我的意思是，她是有史以来最搞笑的人之一，但你说得对，她确实保持着非常低调的作风。这令人钦佩。我很想看到，我希望能看到她更多地出现在大银幕上。至少是的。她太棒了。她总是那么搞笑，威伊也是，就像我们刚才说的，每次看到她，我都只想和她一起玩。我只想，是的，你知道的，到处胡闹，演个小品，操，她就是那种生来就注定要做这行的人。是的，我是最棒的“天生喜剧人”……不管怎样。
Sean, what do you have to get done there around the house before the troops show up? I had to Well, you know, there's no pool because my you know talk about a high-class problems But I have a little pool in the back and it's it's being worked on so they're bummed about that So but I said there's an ocean a half hour away with lots of water in it So they might go swim there. Oh because they're working on the pool. Yeah So you're not would you go with them to the ocean? Do you ever go to the ocean? No. No, why do you not like you don't like sand? I don't like I don't like heat. I don't like the cold water
肖恩，在军队（孩子们）出现之前，你得在家里把什么事情搞定？我得……好吧，你知道的，这里没有游泳池，因为我的（你知道的，这算是有钱人的烦恼吧），但我在后面有一个小泳池，目前正在施工中，所以他们对此有点失望。但我跟他们说，半小时车程外就有一个大洋，里面有满满的水。所以他们可能会去那里游泳。哦，因为泳池在施工。是的。那你不会跟他们一起去海边吗？你从来不去海边吗？不去。不，为什么？你不喜欢沙子吗？我不喜欢。我讨厌炎热。我讨厌冷水。
Well, what about if you went with a nice parasol? And you kind of spin it as you're walking a little bit. That's it. You know what stop coming up with such great ideas That is a pair of aqua socks your feet don't burn on the sand and in your spinning parasol You like you don't like the beach. I love it I don't mind it, but I do find it's overrated and that's that's probably because I just grew up out here And it was just like well, okay It's just a line and then a bunch of water. That's right, you know, and it doesn't change until you get to Hawaii But the difference the California beaches, it's a different animal
好吧，如果你撑一把漂亮的遮阳伞呢？走路的时候还能转一转。就是这样。你知道吗？别再想出这么棒的主意了。那是水上袜（aqua socks），这样你的脚在沙子上就不会被烫伤了，再加上你的旋转遮阳伞。你就是不喜欢海滩。我挺喜欢的。我不介意，但我确实觉得它被高估了，这可能只是因为我是在这儿长大的，觉得它无非就是——好吧，一条海岸线加上一堆水。就是这样，你知道的，而且在去夏威夷之前，景色都不会变。但加州的海滩与众不同，它是不一样的物种。
It's not like because it's always a little bit chillier, etc And it's kind of cloudy the water and the water is water's cold most like very cold most of the year except for like August September you can't really swim in it and then be You know unless you really like cold water, but I I love the beach man. I can't get it. Oh god Yeah, yeah, yeah, I could be good thing about something California There's not a lot of the bigger sharks down in Southern, California, so you don't have to worry about that occasional bye SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjurf SmartLess There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它不像……因为总是有点凉飕飕的等等。而且海水有点浑浊，海水在一年中的大部分时间里都很冷，除了八月和九月左右，你基本上没法在里面游泳，除非你真的很喜欢冷水。不过我超爱海滩，伙计。我就是离不开它。哦天哪。是的，是的，是的。加州海岸有个好处，就是南加州没有太多的大白鲨，所以你不用担心这个，偶尔会有一次……SmartLess 完全由班巴科（Benbarbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·安杰尔（Rob Amjurf）有机且手工打造。SmartLess 本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。